72 lives lost
72 families destroyed
72 reasons to make sure another tragedy
like grenfell cannot happen again
it's been five years since the fire but
for the bereaved and survivors that time
has stood still
the pain in this community is everywhere
it's still written on the walls on the
railings on the faces of those trying to
fight on
hanan wahhabi survived the fire that
night her brother abdul aziz and his
family did not
you can see the impact obviously they
have cleaned it
my brother was wearing this when he died
uh
so i have this in my bedroom
you keep it next to you yeah yeah
henan has little left from her flat or
her brothers just memories they were a
loving family
um there was a lot of laughter a lot of
joking
a lot of dry humor in that household
there was
they held onto both cultures the british
culture and the moroccan culture you
know you'd go in and you'd see
the
you'd see like british flag
british flag and then you'd see like you
know
moroccan ceramics in the house it was it
was you know
yeah
it was nice to see that
after the fire hernan and her two
children were left to live in one hotel
room for 18 months
i just remember
as a parent you want to protect the
children from seeing um
you know your difficulties and your
challenges there was no protecting them
from that
um
i just remember collapsing um constantly
i got to the point where i would
lock myself in the bathroom just so my
children wouldn't see
but it didn't mean they couldn't hear
she now has somewhere to live but she
doesn't call it home grenfell was my
home
and i still see that as my home
i mean there were times when
i might be driving
and i forget
that grandfather happened and
it's like committed to every days and
i'm driving towards the tower
and then i'm like oh my god where are
you going you don't live there anymore i
miss everything about grenfell tower
now it just feels very lonely it i feel
very very
very lonely
for comfort and support hanan doesn't go
far
down the street is manira mahmoud she
also survived the fire she also lost
someone she loved
manira and hernan don't talk about what
happened on the 14th of june 2017
they don't need to
mentally yeah
i think i didn't believe in mental
illness so mental disturbance trauma
stress depression
all of us are victim of it
missing someone that you know your
children are calling mom
auntie
it's just painful
as the years have gone on rather than
starting to heal many people here have
told me that their trauma is getting
worse that they feel weaker and more
exhausted with a continued fight for
answers and for justice
what's hard for the bereaved is that it
feels like nothing has changed yet
everything in their lives has
i am not who i am who i was before grant
fell
sorry
sorry
i worked for over 20 years in education
in september of 2017.
even though
my family hadn't all been found at that
point
i went back to work
uh
and not because
i was able to
perform my job adequately
that was the only place
that was the same for me
that was my safe place
but last year hernan made the decision
to leave the job she loved it was too
much
yes
we smile we may laugh we may joke
but the only way we do that is to whack
on plasters in every single hole that we
have we have wounds our wounds are
massive
we cover them
but we can only cover them for
just for a brief period and then
literally when those doors close you
don't see us we are broken
we all know how the grenfell fire
started what's unclear is how this will
all end the ongoing public inquiry has
revealed a catalogue of failures yet not
one person has been charged with a crime
and it's this absence of accountability
that five years on is still at the heart
of the trauma here charlotte lomas sky
news